[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كل الكون وما يحتويه من نجوم وسدوم وكواكب
متحرك وفلسفه الحياه الوجوديه مبنيه على
هذه الحركه من الحياه الى الممات فحركه
الارض حول نفسها ينتج عنها شروق وغروب
الشمس وهو يعبر عن اليوم وحركه الارض حول
الشمس ينتج عنها الفصول الاربعه وهي تعبر
عن السنه وحركه القمر حول الارض ينتج عنها
اشكال القمر وهو يعبر عن الشهر وهذه
الحركات الثلاث هي الحياه قل الذي ملا
التشاؤم قلبه ومضى يضيق حولنا الافاق سر
السعاده حسن ظنك بالذي خلق الحياه وقسم
الارزاق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فمرور الوقت مرتبط بالاحساس البشري
فالانسان السعيد يمر عليها الوقت مثل
البرق والانسان الحزين يتباطؤ عليه مرور
الوقت ورمضان يقع بين اقصر واطول شهور
السنه والعامه يسمون شهر شعبان بل قصير
وشهر شوال بطويل مرت سنينه بالقصال
وبالهنا فكانها من قصرها ايام ثم ان كانت
ايام وهجر بعدها فكانها من طولها اعوام ثم
انفنت تلك السنون واهلها فكانهم وكانهم
احلام
[موسيقى]